the reason why Tom wanted to lie about
it is because
it's a really bad look too
hook up with someone's boyfriend
in their own house
when they've gone out of town
especially for like a funeral of all
things
the Vanderpump reunion shocker Raquel
Levis turned on Tom Sandoval revealing
the hookup he wanted to keep secret I
was glad she finally told the truth did
you guys have sex multiple times in
Mexico yeah so it was like a regular
ongoing entertainment too it sounds like
as of Mexico yeah I mean yeah it's weird
because we've seen her go from like
she's a lost soul to full breakdown like
I've been trying to protect Tom so now
I'm like do I feel I don't know where
it's like taking a hit of acid I mean I
even suggest I was like maybe like what
would Ariana think about like having me
as an addition and he was like no no she
would not be into that
was worried for Raquel's mental health
going into the reunion
um I mean I still am yes watching Raquel
take on all the attacks and in tears was
definitely a lot E.T has learned that
she has spent the last 68 days in an
inpatient Behavioral Health and Trauma
facility we're told she has learned from
her mistakes and is looking forward to
sharing the quote unfiltered truth when
she comes out
as for Ariana well she's the queen of
quips
cheese grater you're a dementor I know
you like Harry Potter you're ugly you're
hideous I know you're rotten on the
inside rotten
like a moldy piece of fruit rotten last
night Sandoval's band shared a
screenshot of the death threats they've
been receiving this shade he threw
during the reunion oh it definitely
didn't help you know who he did sleep
with after him and Raquel started
sleeping together me
you know she kept her t-shirt on it was
really hot
that was a bad line will your face said
it all it was so bad
chick and just a T-shirt and no pants
Ariana quickly capitalized on the crude
comment with new merch featuring Tom's
diss in this 35 T-shirt with a not safe
for work caption moving forward I'm
looking for something premium yet don't
worry about Ariana that's her tossing
aside Sandoval's classic white nail
polish in a new battery commercial don't
settle for basic the 37 year old is on
the new cover of glamor and her sandwich
shop with Katie is expected to open this
summer just in time for the Vanderpump
cameras our plan is to launch into
season 11 in a few weeks it is within
sight as far as we're concerned at this
point the entire group will be back the
plan is that we will see how this group
picks up the pieces from what everyone
has just seen